ja meine Damen und Herren und da ist es
doch schneller gegangen als wir erwartet
haben Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes steht jetzt
hier auf den Programm mir ist nicht ganz
klar wo die Abstimmung geblieben sind
ohne Aussprache die waren hier
eigentlich viel länger angesetzt oder
Wolfgang Kopie hat so viel Gas gegeben
jedenfalls kann ich Ihnen das nicht
genau beantworten aber es redet bereits
Bernd Hermann zu diesem Punkt von den
Bündnis Grünen und den wollen wir jetzt
reden lassen das wäre nicht nur äußerst
und solidarisch nein es wird auch
unseren gesellschaftlichen Frieden aufs
Äußerste gefährden
der Staat aber trägt die Verantwortung
für alle BürgerInnen und muss in einer
akuten Notlage Eingreifen er muss die
vorhandenen Energiemengen verteilen
damit der lebenswichtige Energiebedarf
von Haushalten von kritischen
Unternehmen gedeckt werden kann genau
das regelt auch die vorliegende Novelle
zum energiesicherungsgesetz
mit dieser Novellierung machen wir
einzelne Regeln noch rechtssicherer
damit in einer wenn auch sehr
unwahrscheinlichen Notlage für alle
gesorgt ist
ein solcher Eingriff durch den Staat
muss natürlich gut abgewogen und
demokratisch legitimiert sein darum
stärken wir die Kontrollfunktion des
Parlaments so kann der Bundestag
innerhalb von zwei Monaten nach
Ausrufung einer Notlage durch die
Bundesregierung diese auch zurücknehmen
aber wir sorgen nicht nur für ganz akute
Notlagen vor wir beschleunigen auch den
Anschluss beispielsweise der
lng-terminals eine der vielen Maßnahmen
der Ampelkoalition damit es erst gar
nicht zur Notlagen kommt wir stellen
sicher dass die notwendigen Komponenten
für den Bau von Gasleitungen zur
Verfügung stehen und das gilt
insbesondere auch ja für Röhren die für
die Bauphase von Nordstemmen 2
vorgehalten wurden und jetzt nicht mehr
gebraucht worden werden
da solche Rohrleitungen auf dem
Weltmarkt nicht ohne weiteres und nur
mit sehr langen Lieferzeiten zu bekommen
werden muss als letztes Mittel der Staat
zur Sicherung der Energieversorgung
Zugriff auch darauf Verhalten gleiches
gilt für die Möglichkeit zur
Einsichtnahme in Dokumentationen
Unterlagen um solche technischen Anlagen
errichten zu können kurzfristig braucht
es den schnellen Ausbau der LG Terminals
auch wenn uns das als Grünen am
allerwichtigsten wir uns wünschen denn
mittel und langfristig helfen uns nur
die erneuerbaren Energien und mehr
Energieeffizienz
als Ampel haben wir deswegen die größte
Novelle des erneuerbaren Energien
Gesetzes und massive steuerlich
Erleichterung für Solaranlagen
beschlossen die Flächenbereitstellung
für Windkraft gestärkt und werden in
wenigen Wochen das auch nicht vergessen
bitte das erste deutsche
Energieeffizienzgesetz beschließen und
es gehört dazu Speicherung in
verschiedenen Formen vollkommen korrekt
und deswegen haben wir auch noch in dem
Entschließungsantrag der dem beigefügtes
ganz klar geregelt und ganz klar Zeichen
gesetzt dass wir mit der
wasserstoffkonzeption Vorankommen müssen
dass wir auch von der EU die
entsprechende Rahmensetzung brauchen
dass die Regierung das bmwk tätig werden
kann dabei und wir wünschen uns dass es
wichtig zu Jahres miteinander Vorlage
dazu um auch mitbestimmen und Einfluss
nehmen zu können denn für uns Grüne ist
das der Wasserstoff nicht das
erheilmittel werden nämlich
Speicherstoff und keine primären Energie
ist und wir wünschen diesen effizient
einzusetzen dort wo wir ihn brauchen wo
wir in dringend brauchen aber dort nicht
Ineffizienz das Wort zu reden sondern
wirklich effiziente Schonung von
natürlichen und von leitungs- zu tragen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
schönen guten Tag liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und liebe Besucher auf den
besuchertribünen und der nächste Redner
der Debatte ist Fabian kramling für die
[Applaus]
so Fabian gramling jetzt für die cdu/csu
und Yvonne Marquardt hat jetzt das
Präsidium hier im Deutschen Bundestag
übernommen und es geht hier in der
Debatte um die Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes Fabian
Situation Entscheidungen die Regierungen
mittragen dass sie auf Fristen
verzichten um auch wichtige
Entscheidungen zeitnah zu ermöglichen
und deshalb habe ich auch wenig
Verständnis für manche Äußerungen bei
den Debatten in den letzten Wochen denn
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
ich möchte eins vorweg mal ganz klar
sagen sie regieren hier in Deutschland
sie haben die Mehrheit im Deutschen
Bundestag und deshalb müssen auch sie
für ihre Politik gerade stehen wer
regiert der kann sich nicht bei jeder
Entscheidung hinter der Opposition
Verstecken der regiert der muss für
seine Entscheidungen auch endlich mal
gerade stehen
und wir stecken mitten in einer
Energiekrise und inmitten dieser
Energiekrise haben Sie sich entschlossen
Kraftwerke abzuschalten und auch vom
Netz zu nehmen und das ohne einen
belastbaren Plan woher die Energie in
Zukunft denn herkommen soll ich finde
diese Entscheidung und verantwortbar
aber damit nicht genug sie haben
beschlossen auf Kraftwerke in Zukunft
verzichten zu wollen obwohl der Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien ja gerade
stockt die Energiebranche wegen ihrer
Politik in einer Schockstarre verharrt
und keine Planungssicherheit hat und
gerade deshalb wäre es jetzt so wichtig
die von ihnen im Koalitionsvertrag
verabschiedete und versprochene
Fortschreibung des Wasserstoff der
wasserstoffstrategie auch endlich hier
im Hohen Haus zu diskutieren
eigentlich hätten sie Ende des Jahres
also in fünf Wochen ihr Konzept zum
wasserstoffnetzausbau hier vorstellen
müssen und natürlich machen die
laufenden Verhandlungen und laufenden
Gespräche zum Aufbau des
wasserstoffnetzes in Brüssel die
Planungen schwieriger der
Änderungsantrag der Regierungsfraktionen
einen Zwischenbericht zum Netzausbau in
Deutschland Mitte des Jahres 23
vorzulegen ist aber maximal ein Erfolg
gegenüber dem Wirtschaftsministerium für
die Branchen für die Unternehmen in
unserem Land die auf den Wasserstoff in
Zukunft angewiesen sind die davon
abhängig sind für alle
wasserstoffakteure ist der heutige
Beschluss ein fatales Zeichen
denn bei der Frage wie wir unsere
Energieversorgung in Zukunft sichern
wollen geht es um nichts anderes als
unserem als um unsere Zukunftsfähigkeit
es geht um unsere Wirtschaftskraft es
geht um Arbeitsplätze und am Ende geht
es um unseren Wohlstand und was wir
brauchen ist jetzt eine Strategie wie
wir und woher wir den Wasserstoff in
Zukunft beziehen können wir brauchen
eine Strategie über Netze und über
Speichermöglichkeiten und die Investoren
brauchen jetzt Klarheit und
Planungssicherheit und deshalb fordert
die ampelregierung auf machen sie
endlich einen energiestresstest für den
Winter 23 24 sorgen Sie schnellstmöglich
für klare Rahmenbedingungen beim
Wasserstoff hochlaufen in Deutschland
und hören Sie auf ständig die Schuld bei
Opposition zu suchen vielen Dank
ja meine Damen und Herren wir sind in
einer haushaltswoche vielleicht sind sie
ein wenig verwundert dass es hier um ein
Gesetz geht nämlich das Energie
Sicherheitsgesetz das hat der Bundestag
am Dienstag beschlossen mit der Mehrheit
des Hauses hier zwei Art fremde Gesetze
heute hier zu beraten der nächste Redner
in der Debatte bringt merkt jetzt von
der SPD
Jahrzehnte und auch der nachfolgende
Winter wird echt nicht ohne werden
möglicherweise wird er noch
herausfordernder als der jetzige und der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
der energiekrieg gegen Europa zwingen
uns dazu wichtige Ziele parallel
anzugehen und das unter höchstem
Zeitdruck
die wichtigen Aufgaben die wir
miteinander vereinen müssen sind hier
zum einen der Schutz des Klimas der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien zum
anderen das Schaffen von
Versorgungssicherheit bei Gas bei Strom
und bei den anderen Ressourcen die wir
benötigen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich habe es schon mal gesagt aber es
macht sie auch nicht schlechter die SPD
geführte Ampelkoalition hat in den
letzten sechs Monaten schon mehr
gerissen als die CDU geführte
Bundesregierung in 16 Jahren trotz
Corona trotz liefern trotz Energiekrise
und trotz krieg meine Damen und Herren
lassen Sie mich noch mal in Erinnerung
rufen mit dem osterpaket haben wir die
größte klimaschutzreform der deutschen
Geschichte beschlossen wir haben die
ausschreibungsmengen deutlich erhöht die
Wertschöpfung in Deutschland durch
konkrete Ausschreibungskriterien
gestärkt Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren haben wir
entschlackt und so den Ausbau angeguckt
und von russischen Gas haben wir uns
unabhängig gemacht wir haben
Lieferverträge mit alternativen
Lieferanten geschlossen und das muss man
sich noch mal verdeutlichen wir haben 50
Milliarden Tonnen eines
die Trägers einfach mal mit anderen
liefern Lieferanten ausgetauscht was ist
das für ein Erfolg was ist das für ein
Erfolg dieser Ampel meiner Damen und
wir haben erneuerbaren Strom verstärkt
ins Netz gebracht durch die Aufhebung
von ökodeckeln und die Flexibilisierung
unserer Stromleitung
Kohlekraftwerke haben wir reaktiviert um
Gas zu sparen und ja um letzte
Befürchtung zu zerstreuen haben wir auch
die letzten drei verbliebenen
Atomkraftwerke am Netz gelassen bis zum
April dann ist Schluss die zwei
wichtigsten Ergebnisse Nummer 1 unsere
Stromversorgung ist gesichert Nummer 2
die Gasspeicher sind voll und auch wenn
sie das nicht gerne hören liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Opposition
das sind Erfolge die weltweit anerkannt
werden in Europa in der Welt wird
durchaus wahrgenommen wie lange
Deutschland konservativ gebremst wurde
und was innerhalb kürzester Zeit jetzt
möglich ist mit der nötigen
Entschlossenheit die wir an den Tag
legen meine Damen und Herren
in den vergangenen Monaten
in den vergangenen Monaten haben wir als
Deutscher Bundestag nicht nur die
Voraussetzung geschaffen für volle
Gasspeicher und eine Stromproduktion auf
Hochtouren wir haben der Bundesregierung
auch eine Reihe von Instrumenten an die
Hand gegeben das Ziel im Fall der Fälle
schnell handlungsfähig zu sein und die
Energieversorgung bei Engpässen
sicherstellen zu können
in Kern kann man das im Grunde auf zwei
einfache Nenner bringen erstens in den
deutschen Wohnzimmern soll es immer so
warm bleiben dass niemand frieren muss
und zweitens unser Mittelstand schützen
wir selbst wenn das Gas mal knapp wird
soll die Lichter hier nicht ausgehen wir
tun alles was nötig ist um in Zeiten des
russischen energiekrieges die
Versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
dazu gehört auch eine funktionierende
Energieinfrastruktur meine Damen und
Herren ohne Windrad keine Windenergie
ohne salatdächer kein Solarstrom und ja
ohne Pipeline kein Glas wir werden neben
den Erneuerbaren noch länger auf Erdgas
angewiesen sein die Bürger heizen damit
die Bäcker backen damit die Industrie
produziert damit deshalb ist es gut dass
die Koalition entschlossen auf den Weg
geht und für die Infrastruktur an der
deutschen Küste alles bereitet hat
Brunsbüttel Lubmin Stade Wilhelmshaven
dort soll künftig Flüssigkeit
deutsche Netz eingespeist werden
Wilhelmshaven ist wie bekannt ist schon
im Rekordtemperatur fertiggestellt dort
werden wir Mitte Dezember schon die
ersten Lieferungen bekommen Brunsbüttel
wahrscheinlich noch in diesem Jahr
Lubmin und Stade kommen dann danach
allein in Lubmin werden 5 Milliarden
Kubikmeter gasanlanden für schlankere
Genehmigungsverfahren haben wir gesorgt
und das sogar bis an den Rand das
Machbaren und das möglichen sind wir
hier gegangen das ist die rechtliche
Seite doch nehmen wir mal folgendes an
was ist wenn der Bau genehmigt ist wir
aber nicht genug Rohre haben um das
lng-termine zu bauen wenn die Rohre
nicht am Markt verfügbar sind denn
schließlich hat Putin selbst das größte
Stahlwerk Europas in Stuttgart das war
in Mario Pool in diesen Krisenzeiten mit
teilweise
Lieferketten mit Energiepolitik als
Waffe sind das keine abwegigen Fragen
mehr und wenn das schlecht läuft dann
steht in den Startlöcher wir laufen los
bis kurz vor die Ziele da Linie und
laufen dann vor eine Wand und das können
wir uns nicht erlauben und deswegen sind
wir jetzt bei der Reform des aktuellen
Energie sicherungsgesetz wenn wir sagen
müssen wir auch sagen wenn wir Rohre
oder andere Teile die für eine
Infrastruktur am Markt nicht verfügbar
sind
brauchen dann müssen wir in der letzte
in der Lage sein als zu enteignen als
allerletztes Mittel als ultima ratio
muss das möglich sein nicht zum
Selbstzweck
vielen Dank nicht zum Selbstzweck
sondern im Sinne der
Versorgungssicherheit dieses Landes für
die Haushalte und Unternehmen der Leute
die hier leben und Wirtschaft der A sagt
muss auch B sagen und niemand hat die
Absicht zu enteignen aber 5 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas sind wichtig für warme
Wohnungen und heiße Industrieöfen
und diese fünf Milliarden Kubikmeter
dürfen uns am Ende nicht fehlen weil wir
drei Rohr zu wenig haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden von
weitreichenden Eingriffen von wirklich
starken Befugnissen Befugnissen die aber
in einem solchen Szenario gemäß Artikel
14 des Grundgesetzes gerechtfertigt sind
und möglich sind das ist also kein
sozialistischer hexenkrams den wir hier
machen das steht in unserem Grundgesetz
und natürlich muss das entsprechend
entschädigen für die enteigneten zufolge
haben und wer jetzt mit der ddr-keule
wedelt wie es wahrscheinlich gleich von
dieser Ecke hier drüben passieren wird
hat es nicht verstanden oder handelt
einfach unverantwortlich nahezu jeden
Tag wird in Deutschland enteignet zum
Beispiel für eine Straßenbau für den
Schienenbau für die Verkehrswege auch im
Falle unseres Beispiel des lg-terminals
oder anderer Energieinfrastruktur muss
das im Notfall möglich sein
die Interessen einzelner stehen zurück
um in die Interessen der Allgemeinheit
zu schützen von 80 Millionen Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern in Deutschland und im
übrigen auch um solidarisch mit unseren
Nachbarinnen und Nachbarn in Europa zu
sein wenn es sein muss alles andere wäre
fahrlässig
wenn sie verantwortungsvolle Politik
wenn sie verantwortungsvolle Politik im
Sinne der Versorgungssicherheit machen
wollen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von Oppositionen stimmen Sie bitte heute
zu ich schlage auch sehr vor dass sie
auch den Entschließungsantrag
entsprechend denn zwei Punkte darin sind
wirklich essentiell erstens die
Bundesregierung soll neben dem erwähnten
Zwischenbericht auch Eckpunkte für ein
Konzept zum Aufbau des wasserstoffen
letztes vorlegen bei diesem Thema ist
Tempo geboten das wissen wir je eher
Pläne vorliegen desto eher können wir
sie umsetzen in enger Abstimmung mit den
europäischen Regeln die bereits in
Arbeit sind Stichwort Gas und
Wasserstoff binnenmarktpaket und
zweitens wir fordern in der Bundeswehr
von der Bundesregierung eine Monitoring
um immer im Blick zu haben welche
Betriebsstoffe die nicht Energie
Rohstoffe sind am Markt verfügbar sind
und welche nicht das ist wichtig es geht
um kein Produkte und so weiter wir
brauchen einen Überblick darüber wir
begreifen
[Musik]
das Land als ein Schiff was zu steuern
geht dazu muss bekannt sein was auf den
Text passiert alles in den progressiven
Kurs zu halten und deswegen möchte ich
gerne mit den Worten eines Bekannten
schließen Fähnrich Kurs setzen voller
Impuls Energie vielen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Carsten Hilse
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute der Weg in Richtung
Sozialismus wird konsequent beschritten
mit dem neuen energiesicherungsgesetz
schaffen Sie die Voraussetzung
Enteignungen von privat in Unternehmer
noch leichter und rechtssicher
durchzuführen alle sozialistischen
Experimente endeten bisher in der
Katastrophe führten zur Verelendung des
Volkes und kosteten Millionen von
Menschen das Leben die AFD ist die
einzige Partei die sich dieser
Entwicklung konsequent entgegenstellt
nachdem im Fall Juniper der Weg gegangen
wurde durch eine dieser Größe
Energiepolitik und einen von der EU im
Auftrag der USA angezettelten
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen unseren größten
Rohstofflieferanten uniper erst in den
Rand der Pleite zu treiben um sie dann
zu übernehmen legt man nun Hand an das
privat Eigentum
wie wir am Freitag vom
wirtschaftszerstörungsminister erfahren
mussten will man die übrig gebliebenen
Rohre von nordstream 2 enteignen während
er noch von möglicherweise sprach wir
alle wissen dass Sozialisten egal ob sie
braun rot oder bunt sind von jeder
Möglichkeit Gebrauch machen ihre kranke
und menschenverachten Ideologie
durchzusetzen wurde Herr Berg konkreter
Zitat diese Rohre müssen wir mit der
Änderung des energiesicherungsgesetzes
in irgendeiner Weise schaffen in unserem
Besitz zu bringen Zitat Ende deutlicher
kann man sich als Feind der Freiheit
nicht äußern
vornehmlich sollen die Rohre für die
Flüssigkeit Terminals verwendet werden
eines der Hauptziele ist aber
offensichtlich eine mögliche Reparatur
von Nordrhein zu verunmöglichen nachdem
die Bundesregierung keinerlei keinerlei
Schritte unternimmt um die Zerstörung
dieser wichtigen Lebensadern aufzuklären
ja sogar Fragen von Abgeordneten
abbügelt sorgt sie nun dafür dass nie
wieder Gas durch die Pipeline fließt
ganz im Sinne unserer Freunde aus
übersehen man könnte sein dass die
Richtlinienkompetenz der deutschen
Politik nicht beim deutschen
Bundeskanzler sondern beim Präsidenten
der Vereinigten Staaten liegt die FDP
nickt als Verräter der bürgerlichen
Freiheit alles ab gut dass die Herren
Genscher und Lamsdorf diese
trümmertruppe nicht mehr miterleben
müssen aber was macht die Union nichts
sie weigert sich sogar nach bekannt
werden dieses unerhörnchenskandals
wenigstens eine öffentliche Anhörung zu
fordern sie trägt diesen Weg in den
Sozialismus mit sie bietet konstruktive
Gespräche an für den Umbau unserer
Gesellschaft in Richtung
Staatsdirigismus aller China Werte
Kollegen der Union die noch konservativ
denken und ich weiß dass es da noch
einige gibt kehren sie um unterstützen
oder tolerieren sie nicht weiter diesen
katastrophalen Kurs der Sozialisten
legen Sie sich nicht weiter mit Freiheit
sind Demokratie Verächter in
parlamentarische Bettchen und geben Sie
die absurde Blockadehaltung auf gegen
die Werte die sie vor 20 Jahren doch
selbstvertreten haben und gegen die AFD
die diese Werte heute vertritt sie
werden sonst irgendwann den Weg der
Demokratie Christiana gehen und von der
politischen Landkarte verschwinden und
für einige von ihnen
dass wir das direkt Leid vielen Dank
[Applaus]
der Kollege
frau Präsidentin und liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist ja der beste Slot zu
dem man reden kann immer direkt nach der
AFD und ich freue mich ich freue mich
wirklich sehr dass wir alle als
Deutscher Bundestag ja auch dazu
beitragen Energie zu sparen das ist in
der Öffentlichkeit bekannt geworden die
die Büroräume sind hier jetzt auch etwas
in den Temperaturen abgesenkt der ein
oder andere Mitarbeiter fragt manchmal
wo kann ich mich ein bisschen aufwärmen
ich sage dann immer gehe auf den Flur
der afd-fraktion da wird so viel heiße
Luft produziert da ist richtig warm und
das können wir auch können wir auch am
Beispiel können wir auch am Beispiel der
heutigen Debatte mal durch accessieren
wir haben hier eine Situation in der wir
von Russland abgeschnitten worden sind
von der Gasversorgung diese Koalition
hat sich im Frühjahr dieses Jahres auf
den Weg gemacht um trotzdem die
Gasversorgung in diesem Land aufrecht zu
halten wir haben es zwischenzeitlich
nicht nur geschafft unsere Ziele zu
erreichen sondern die Gasspeicher auf
über 100% Füllstand zu erreichen ich
glaube das ist nur aus temperaturgründen
möglich aber ich bin sicher man kann
über 100 Prozent sein und trotzdem
fallen Ihnen noch viele Gründe ein warum
wir denn nicht auf dem richtigen Weg
sind ich würde sagen wir haben nicht nur
unsere Ziele erreicht sondern wir haben
vor allem das Hauptziel erreicht dass
die Menschen und Unternehmen mit
genügend Gas gut durch diesen Winter
kommen werden weil die Menschen sich
anstrengen zu sparen weil wir genügend
Gas organisiert haben und weil wir gut
gerüstet sind auf den Angriff aus
Russland und nun kommen sie hier von
ganz rechts außen mit der mehr wir
würden Leitungen enteignen damit die
Reparatur der Nord streamleitung
verunmöglicht werden würde und wenn sie
ein bisschen technische Kenntnisse wenn
Sie nur ein bisschen technische Kenntnis
hätten dann wüssten sie ja das ist ein
Unterschied macht ob ich eine Leitung
neu baue zum Beispiel zu einer FSI also
einem schwimmende Terminal das dafür
sorgt dass weiter Gas in unserer
östliches Leitungsnetz und nach Bayern
geleitet werden kann oder ob ich
literaturleitungen braucht das sind
nämlich zwei unterschiedliche Leitungen
ihre Behauptung Herr Hülse das hier
Leitungen enteignet werden sollten die
ansonsten für die Reparatur der
nord-stream 2 gebraucht werden und
verwendet werden könnten sie ist
schlicht falsch sie ist Teil ihrer
Demagogie und ihre fehlende technische
Expertise führt dazu dass diese
Demagogie auch noch schlecht ist ich bin
sicher ihren Followern bei Facebook wird
das überhaupt kein wird das überhaupt
kein Schmerz bereiten mir hat es sehr
viel Schmerz bereitet ihnen zuzuhören
und vor allem verbreiten sie hier
Unwahrheiten und ehrlich gesagt meine
Instagram Follower die sagen mir
mittlerweile du erzählst jedes Mal das
Gleiche weil du immer auf die AFD
reagierst und weil du immer so viel
recht richtig stellen musst wird mir
also wünschen dass sie nicht nur ihre
Propaganda in diesem Hause beenden
sondern dass sie sich vielleicht mal
neue vielleicht sogar richtige Argumente
einfallen lassen dann können wir ja
darüber diskutieren
zum Aspekt der Enteignung der
erstens wenn wir es gut machen gar nicht
angewendet werden muss und zweitens
natürlich immer auch hohen Schranken
unterliegen muss möchte ich einmal
darauf hinweisen dass wir den
Gesetzentwurf an wichtigen Stellen
weiter eingeschränkt haben zum einen
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass das
Parlament für den Fall der Sicherung der
Energieversorgung und der Kaskade an
Maßnahmen die dann ergriffen werden
können beteiligt werden muss das ist
etwas was wir in der coronazeit gelernt
haben in einem Jahr unionsgeführten Haus
aus dem es häufig Verordnungen dann über
Nacht gab die dann so ausgegoren nicht
waren dabei haben wir gelernt es ist
erstens besser wann immer möglich die
ganze Regierung zu beteiligen das tun
wir hier zum Beispiel bei den
präventiven Maßnahmen und es ist besser
dafür zu sorgen dass das Parlament bei
wesentlichen Einschränkungen von
Freiheiten das letzte Mitsprache Recht
hat auch dafür haben wir als
Parlamentarier in diesem
Gesetzgebungsverfahren gesorgt und
deswegen möchte ich jedem in diesem Haus
auch den Oppositionsabgeordneten anraten
stimmen Sie diesem Gesetzentwurf heute
zu denn er ermöglicht Ihnen mehr
Mitspracherecht im Falle der
Energieknappheit herzlichen Dank
Michael Kruse war das der
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion gesprochen hat
entschuldigung da muss mich kurz erst
noch mal irritieren der Bundesland
diskutiert über ein ganzes Bündel von
Maßnahmen im Zusammenhang mit dem
energiesicherungsgesetz es geht um den
Ausbau von solar- und Biogas es geht um
Einsparungen und Vorgaben dazu aber eben
auch unmögliche Enteignungen oder
Verstaatlichung also Zwangsmaßnahmen
nächster Redner Ralf lenkert für die
Linksfraktion wurde die staatliche Preis
auf sich zerschlagen
kommunale Stadtwerke werden gegenüber
Konzerne nachteiligt alle
Bundesregierung legten so Stück für
Stück die Versorgungssicherheit unseres
Energiesystems in die Hände von
profitorientierten Unternehmen auch aus
dem Ausland auch aus Russland und ohne
ausreichende Absicherung
an der Börse manipulierten einige
schwarze Schafe den Markt mehrfach
standen wir deshalb kurz vor Blackouts
seit Herbst letzten Jahres kündigen
Händler bestehende Verträge und zwingen
ihre Kunden in teure Neuabschlüsse
Gazprom verursachte mit seinem Eigentum
in Deutschland gasmangel und Spekulanten
nutzen dies zusätzlich egoistisch für
übergewinne aus und Haushalte Handwerk
und Industrie zahlen die Zeche mit
explodierenden Energiekosten das ist
kein Marktversagen das ist normales
Verhalten von Marktteilnehmern zum
steigern und deshalb fordert DIE LINKE
Energieversorgung ist unverzichtbar und
muss der Gesellschaft gehören
unter dem Eindruck der Energiekrise hat
die Ampel den Marktmissbrauch jetzt
weniger gesetzliche Grenzen gesetzt
Unternehmen Händler welche bewusst die
Versorgung Energie gefährden können
enteignet werden und das ist auch das
Mindeste
aber das die Regierung weiterhin zulässt
das am Markt Profitmaximierung durch
Spekulation erreicht werden kann ist
verantwortungslos und das selbst im
Winter viele Familien wegen drohender
Strom und Gas sperren keine
Versorgungssicherheit haben werden ist
unerträglich
die Linke kämpft für dauerhafte
Versorgungssicherheit mit bezahlbaren
Energiekosten wir fordern mehr
Regulierung gegen Spekulation
übergewinn steuern damit Wucher sich
nicht lohnt Festpreise für den
Grundbedarf an Strom Gas-
[Applaus]
ralf lenkert war das zu Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie und den können
Sie morgen früh wieder sehen um 8:45 Uhr
wenn Christian Kindler von Bündnis 90
die Grünen über den Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers und vor allem
auch generell über Fragen der
energiesicherung und der Energiepreise
jetzt letzter Redner in dieser Debatte
Thomas Heilmann aus der Unionsfraktion
Gesellschaft dieses Jahr hatten wir 81
Tage mit Blackouts wir haben nirgendwo
so viel Kohle Energie die in Südafrika
und ist auch die höchsten Preise
verglichen mit anderen afrikanischen
Ländern also diese Gesellschaft keine
Lösung
jetzt zu dem Gesetz hier die
Bundesregierung hat in der Energiekrise
durch das aus vieles gerade am Anfang
richtig gemacht den haben wir auch
zugestimmt diesen Gesetz können wir
nicht zustimmen
denn es ist hastig gemacht oberflächlich
und unschlüssig es geht damit los dass
sie ja sagen die entschädigungsregel
müsste der Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts angepasst
werden meine erste Frage ist wir haben
in den letzten sieben Monaten fünfmal
das Gesetz geändert warum muss das jetzt
eigentlich so hastig sein die es gibt
keine neue Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts warum kommt
das jetzt erst und warum sind dann die
Vorlagen in allerletzter Minute konkret
am Abend vor der Sitzung um 9 Uhr
morgens kommt sie dann abends um 9:30
Uhr per E-Mail die letzten Änderung
die Frage warum hat Nord Stream 2
eigentlich 40 km Röhren übrig konnte in
der Bundesregierung niemand im Ausschuss
beantworten es findet sich aber wenn man
sucht das liegt an der dänischen
Regelung die lange nicht gesagt haben ob
die Röhren um Bornholm rum müssen oder
nicht dann hat Nord Stream zwei
vorsichtshalber 40 km zusätzlich gekauft
deswegen gibt es diese Röhren überhaupt
nun ist trotzdem zwei nach ihrer eigenen
Aussage bereit diese Röhren zu verkaufen
da wurde uns im Ausschuss gesagt naja
aber der russische Gesellschaft da der
könnte nicht zustimmen hat zu ihm zwei
befindet sich im Schweizer Recht des
Moratoriums das ist ungefähr das was wir
planen Insolvenz in Deutschland nehmen
das heißt der Insolvenzverwalter muss
zustimmen nicht der Gesellschaft haben
alle diese Fragen sind unbeantwortet
geblieben bis jetzt oder auch in dieser
Debatte nicht beantwortet und es gibt
noch eine letzte Frage die mir Fachleute
gestellt haben wir bauen jetzt 40 km
hören direkt neben nordsystem 2 wir
könnten auch in das nordischen zwei
Leitung einen Themen T-Stück einsetzen
und die vorhandene Leitung nutzen das
Dinge schneller es wäre wesentlich
billiger und das wäre Umwelt schon
all diese Fragen sind nicht beantwortet
unsere Alternative ist machen sie höhere
präzisionen wir haben dazu den Antrag
gemacht in der wir noch mal dargestellt
haben wie wir die Energiepolitik
gestalten würden ein Punkt ist nicht
Drittel halten sie würde ich noch gerne
nennen im Finanzausschuss geht es gerade
auch maximal chorisch zu ihre
Streitigkeiten führen dazu dass sie
undurchführbare Beschlüsse darstellen
insbesondere ist der geplante
abschöpfungsmechanismus genauso Europa
rechtswidrig und genauso
verfassungsrechtlich wie die
gescheiterte Gasanlage
es behindert den Ausbau von erneuerbaren
Anlagen es lässt jetzt schon die
Strompreise tragen treiben und sie
benachteiligen damit auch noch
ausgerechnet sie als sogenannte
klimakkoalition die erneuerbaren
Energieanlagen gegenüber ökohol Öle und
Atomenergie sie schöpfen fiktive Gewinne
nur bei der Erneuerbaren ab ich halte
das für ausdrücklich verfassungswidrig
und es ist auch ausdrücklich im Unrecht
eigentlich ausgeschlossen stoppen Sie
diesen Sinn gerne ich wollte stoppen Sie
diesen Unsinn stoppen Sie dieses Chaos
und behandeln Sie bitte die erneuerbaren
Energien genauso wie sie Öl Kohle und
Atom zu tun vielen Dank
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den von
den Fraktionen SPD
eingebracht Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung
des energiesicherungsgesetzes und andere
energiewirtschaftliche Vorschriften der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
empfiehlt unter
buchstabierung auf Drucksache 45/61 den
Gesetzentwurf der ampelfraktionen auf
Drucksache 43-28 in der ausschussfassung
einzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die den
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Anzeichen
lernte Koalition wer stimmt da gegen
Ende
AFD mehr enthält sich die Fraktion DIE
LINKE den Gesetzentwurf ist damit es
weitere Beratung angenommen wir kommen
zum dritten Beratung und zur
Schlussabstimmung die Fraktion der AFD
hat hier namentliche Abstimmung verlangt
die Abstimmung erfolgt in der westlobby
sie haben zur Abgabe ihre Stimme nach
der Eröffnung der Abstimmung 20 Minuten
Zeit die schriftführerinnen und
Schriftführer haben ihre Plätze
eingenommen die Urnen sind besetzt ich
eröffne damit die namensliche Abstimmung
und die abstimmungsormen werden um
13:50 Uhr geschlossen
das bevorstehende Ende der namentliche
Abstimmungen würde ich Ihnen vorab noch
mal bekannt geben und die Bekanntgabe
das Ergebnis
30 Minuten also nach dem Zusatzpunkt 5
daran schließt sich dann unmittelbar die
Abstimmung über die Entschließung des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
sowie über einen Entschließungsantrag
der Fraktion der CDU CSU
und jetzt rufe ich den Zusatzpunkt 5 auf
die zweite und dritte Beratung des von
der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
Bundesfernstraßen mautgesetzes und das
bedeutet das ist ab dem 1 Januar 23
höhere Mautgebühren für LKW geben wird
auf deutschen Straßen die der Bundestag
passt damit die Rechtsprechung in
Deutschland einer europäischen
Richtlinie an man erhofft sich nebenbei
auch noch deutliche Mehreinnahmen von
600 Millionen Euro pro Jahr im Moment
bringt die Lkw-Maut 7,6 Milliarden in
das deutsche staatssekel im nächsten
Jahr oder ab nächstem Jahr sollen das
dann 8,3 Milliarden sein pro Jahr und
ähm ja wir werden sehen was der
Bundesverkehrsminister gleich zu diesem
Thema sagt er wird nämlich der erste
Redner sein die in dieser Debatte die
jetzt parallel zu der Abstimmung gleich
aufgerufen werden wird während die
Abgeordneten in der Lobby jetzt ihre
Experten einwerfen zum den Änderungen am
energiesicherungs